[Applause]
welcome to swipe here's what's in store
for you this week Thomas finds out how a
new app is helping power the fight
against cancer I join groups of five and
six-year-olds playing with electric Doh
and Lucy's fighting for survival in the
world of Conan the Barbarian that's
coming up in our games review stay with
us for all of that and let's go look at
the tech stories that made headlines
this week Twitter told it's more than
330 million users to change their
passwords
after a bug was identified it meant some
passwords had been stored in plain text
on its internal computer system Facebook
announced its going to begin offering
its own dating service focused on
long-term relationships other news from
the social networks annual developer
conference included a new way for people
to clear their browsing history from the
site engineers have been developing a
solar-powered drone that will be able to
stay airborne for up to a year bae
systems and tech company Prismatic have
joined forces to work on the unmanned
vehicle they hope to begin test flying
next year the drone could serve as a
low-cost option for surveillance or to
bring communications to remote areas the
headset designed to make you lean that
we previously covered here on swipe has
picked up a gong at the Yahoo Sports
technology Awards Moe Deus
took the fest new concept or Innovation
Award Fitbit won most innovative
wearable and the best app award went to
Ordnance Survey and pupils from a school
in London have been named winners at the
world's largest robotics competition in
America the 14 year olds from Queen
Elizabeth School in Barnet beat off
competition from 400 teams of youngsters
from 40 countries to take the vex IQ
challenge Excellence Award they were
judged on research robot design
programming and driving skills
now so you might think that when you're
asleep you can't do anything useful
except recharge your batteries but this
week Thomas has been to Imperial College
London to find out how when you nod off
you could be using your smartphone to
contribute to finding a cure for cancer
now fancy joining the fight against
cancer and all you have to do is well
almost nothing at all
dream lab an app developed by Imperial
College London and the Vodafone
foundation lets you join the battle
against cancer by turning your
smartphone into an overnight powerhouse
so we've got the dream lab app here on
this phone Kiril you were the scientific
team leader on this app can you tell me
how it is that it works sure when you
plug in your phone and the power dream
lab it downloads a tiny portion of our
huge scientific projects from the cloud
process the data and deposit the results
back to us so this chopping up of the
different calculations that need to be
done doing them on smartphones and
sending them back
surely that speeds everything out quite
a lot the same calculations performed on
a personal desktop computer could have
taken over 300 years if we combine the
power of a hundred hours of smart phones
these calculations can be done within
the two to three months time by farming
out the work to idle smartphones the
project hopes to reduce not only the
time it takes but also the cost which
usually comes with cloud computing when
it comes to medical research we've seen
the potential of pooled processing power
before when the human genome was first
sequenced by a global network of
computers by using the same concept on
our smart phones this app hopes to
create a bank of information to be used
by cancer labs around the world after
being released earlier this week the app
achieved over six thousand downloads in
just 24 hours when you're at sleep and
you're charging a phone at night your
phone's processing power is just lying
there idle and if we can harness that
then we can help with the cancer
research problem that Imperial has got
so we're asking people when they
their phone to also open the dream lab
app so we can use that collective
processing power now anyone can get
involved if you've got a smartphone you
don't just have to be a Vodafone
customer the team hoped to have a
network of hundreds of thousands of
phones in no time at all all helping
forge the next step in the battle
against all forms of cancer
Thomas Newton Sky News now here's why
I'm at a school this week over the years
we've covered a lot of educational
tektite on swipe but today I'm going to
be getting hands-on with a kit that
claims to teach children as young as
four how to build electric circuits with
dough and superheroes there's some
important learning happening here these
children are helping superheroes by
playing with a kit that sets the
missions online to create things in real
life using conductive dough and
electricity Josef Elise and I are
building a wall so that Hulk's fist can
smash into it when Hulk's fist hits the
wall it completes an electric circuit
and makes a noise the electric Hero kit
from stem toy makers tech will save us
was a collaboration with Disney and
Marvel Studios which explains the
superhero theme these five and
six-year-olds are still learning how to
read but now they're getting to grips
with electricity sixty-five percent of
kids that are in primary school today
will have jobs that have not been
invented yet
which is pretty amazing and one of the
big ways that kids will begin to
navigate that future is by being problem
solvers but we're excited about is
seeing kids like this kind of coming to
life when they see how it works when
they see that they can actually be
producers of it that they can actually
express themselves with it that it's not
just a glorified television screen other
tasks involve making lights work like
here on these freshly made superhero
badges
black wire in the bottom educational
tech toys are popping up all the time so
I wondered how do you spot a good one
from a gimmick to find a good one it's
where you've got children where they can
explore the science or the maths or the
technology or the electronics through
something that they're enjoying and
having fun with so they don't actually
realize they're learning it is for too
young to be learning how to create
electric circuits not at all the younger
the better
in fact there's this idea that we are
born a scientists that babies start to
observe and explore the world around
them so the more they can explore the
more they can find out at an early age
the more then they'll be able to learn
and take with them as they go on and
further up their education as the
superhero missions are completed they
get harder and I'm told the tasks are
limitless
after all hero's work is never done time
for our video games review now and
there's no dough but Lucy has brought a
new way to play Donkey Kong Country
tropical freeze actually came out a few
years ago on the Nintendo Wii
but now the Nintendo re releasing it for
the switch which means you no longer
have to play it in the confines of your
living room it's a side-scrolling
platformer in game featuring Donkey Kong
who everyone knows and loves but it's
not just Donkey Kong it's members of his
family too so you can go through these
beautiful colorful levels and have
various members of the Kong family help
you out if you get into trouble the
original game was known for being quite
challenging so what they've done for the
switch version is they've added in a
brand new mode where you don't place
Donkey Kong you play as funky Kong who
was actually in the original game but
now he's a playable character you can
play as funky Kong and make it a little
bit easier on yourself honestly if you
like joyas Nintendo platformers then
you're gonna have a great time with
tropical freeze
Coenen exiles has actually been playable
for quite a while but now it's finally
coming out its final finished form but
that's not to say that's not still
getting new updates and new things added
to it it is a survival game in an
open-world version of the Conan the
Barbarian world you don't actually play
as Conan you play as a character that
you create yourself but you did get
rescued by him at the very beginning of
the game and then you kind of are free
to set out and explore but most
importantly you have to survive all the
while you have to build settlements for
yourself and build new weapons and
armour and crafting and of course there
are things that you have to fight so not
only are there environmental things but
you can also fight against your friends
if you want to do some PvP if you are
interested in any way in survival games
it's a lot of fun you can play on PC
Xbox one and ps4 Nintendo Lavo is the
other big release this month and it is
very very different to what you might
expect from a video game because part of
it is cardboards I sent all this myself
I had a very fun afternoon doing so
you'll first make creations out of the
cardboard sheets if you have a Nintendo
switch system you buy the labo pack and
what happens is they give you these
on-screen instructions and you build the
things out of cardboard they give you
all the things that you need what labo
does so cleverly is you can attach your
Nintendo switch controllers to it they
fit in slot in and you can play games
using these controllers that you've just
made out of cardboard
Nintendo hosted in this very very clever
thing where they reward exploration
curiosity and learning so you can
explore it tells you exactly why it
works how it works so if it breaks you
know exactly what to do it gives you the
ability to make your own toy cons and
actually design games with it yourself
and of course because it's cardboard you
can really get your artistic side out in
a world where we just play loads of you
know beautiful triple-a games and
exciting indie games Nintendo are really
thinking outside the box with labo if
you want to basically become a big child
again play with LeBeau
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us again for more
swype next week and in the meantime why
not follow us on twitter at sky news
swipe then you can see what we get up to
throughout the week bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]